back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
I can't hear it and it's not cool bro I
drink too much nyquil oh you want it
really yeah hmm hmm you seem like
somebody yeah I could see you did it
well you seem like somebody would just
like if I think about you in a bed I
think about you being asleep on a nyquil
no or just you don't seem like somebody
that would need up sleep you know
Downers to rest no I don't I shut it
down hard
are you hard full eight hours here
broken really you know you're looking at
me mister eight hours that Mister wha
mr. worldwide you look like you sleep
two hours a night ha ha oh you look like
it dude you've never missed the gravy
okay no I love gravy do you yeah [ __ ]
see that you look like you sprinkled
drugs and gravy really like you sleep an
hour a night have you ever tried
counting sheep Oh ro dude I've got rats
dude I got to get out there and count
him one time like I was having such
trouble sleeping
dude I drove half a state away
encountered a couple random challenge on
them bring some calories
oh yeah the rat King's here wrecking
hitter right now I'm not mad at that the
road to the strap goes through this
big-ass rat hey man what over the back
huh
it's a white rat on there I feel like
that's racist oh it says this past
weekend yeah man I think the rest I just
heard from the Rat King he's themed I'm
making another strap video cuz he got
that new he's got that new piece that
new hitter how nice is that thing it's
strappy boy strap is heavy too he said I
just got a note from the other jake the
snake' care around that [ __ ] snake
everywhere
Jake the quake brother dude the Rat King
oh really he'll shake the earth so
you're here Jake the snake talked about
bringing that rat every or how
exhausting it was you have to bring on
planes and [ __ ] you mean a snake
everywhere dude Jake the snake
I know but can t have someone handle the
snake from you still have like bored
[ __ ] Southwest and put the snake in
the [ __ ] the apartment you called it
a rat a second ago yeah damn I need more
sleep yeah I don't know what you need
dude Derek's here how are we doing Derek
pulling out of this conversation
d
big deal with barnyard shrub over here
get me out of this conference way bro
what up boys you guys ready to do some
get this episode going to do it with
Brendan shrub and tree over on that's
what I know bond
tree the tree and the shrub it's the
tree in does true it's the tree in the
scrub yeah what did I get this going get
this going
hit it hit it hit it that's loud huh so
loud man Jesus it's like one of those
car alarms that would go off around here
throw the football near it yeah no we
thought about yeah you're one guy I
remember in our neighborhood came out
and shot up his own car the alarm went
off and you just came out and [ __ ]
shot it like four why do you do it just
a flex any guys show that he had an
alarm on the car yeah and then the show
he had a gun he's like he was throwing
everything he had ultimate flex gang bra
really beautiful guy to mr. Lyne they
called him did he live in a trap house
do you know what a trap house is no huh
do you know what trap house is you're
asking a rat if he knows what a trap
house is yeah come on bro you look like
you airbnb trap really good let's kick
this off yeah hey what little birdie was
telling me Dee wasn't too fond of how
we're talking about a few episodes ago
look at me son told me that deal was
coming with the heat yeah you racist
bastards well well I mean you mean
racist bastard if I'm races dude I would
know I'll let you know as well okay my
my brain trauma made me racist it's kind
of an excuse oh yeah I liked everyone
before I started getting knocked out oh
yeah yeah I could see that man I could
see you uh yeah but then you changed him
in a big brown to be all inclusive yeah
cuz then I can throw around whatever
words I want yeah people like he's not
bike I'm like but he's big brown you
know he's mauve gives me the right you
know yeah he's plum
mm-hmm sorry dude yeah did we upset
about that man no I'm not upset about
[ __ ] little big brown over here
looking like Drake if he was a hot dog
eating champion
Theo Theo who looks like [ __ ] one of
George Bush's wives won't know either
one but I'm not mad I wasn't man
whatever
don't take the sign off you did you say
you like Drake like what a Bill
Clinton's [ __ ] mistress it'll Debbie's
mistresses dude you're like Jackie
Kennedy can't even think I have a
headache we deserve that yeah we deserve
it let's kick this off you guys ready to
keep going yeah I made the hannam some
fan sent in a couple if you want to hear
him roast this pig this was really funny
though this [ __ ] mrs. Doubtfire this
boy they call it PO in Hawaii when
somebody like Brennan falls in a fire
brennon looks like he drank a bunch of
maple syrup and never swallowed it
[ __ ] great mr. big Canada cheeks over
here and then I feel looks like he runs
a squirrel Fight Club in his backyard
that's from Jordan there's a good man
Todd to pay the bills look here's the
thing you're lazy or maybe you're not
but either way you ain't fixing yourself
something to eat something to drink what
do you want breakfast burrito at 8:00
a.m. about sushi at 9:00 p.m.
yeah well post mates is your buck is
your buddy your best friend post mates
is your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever you can think of
delivery service 365 days a year
everything everything everything man 24
hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring you whatever you
want within the hour no more trips to
the store don't do that you don't even
have to know where the store is man
where's the store I don't know somebody
else does somebody named post not this
it's not Spanish it's post mates and
it'll deliver anything to you anything
you're craving for a limited time post
mates is giving you guys the king
steamed fans $100 a free delivery credit
for your first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app right now
and use code Kay 80s 2019 that's right
anything you're craving post mates can
deliver for a limited time
that's right post mates giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app right now
and use code Kay 80s to 0 1 9 hit
anything you need anytime you need it
download the post mates app save with
the code k 80s 201 9 post MOT this how
do you buy that King support the podcast
oh man I was up late last night doing
what broken sleep no neighborhood watch
fine - that's a job man named you talk
about neighbors looking out for each
other yeah and I have I do I carry three
fat flashlights just in case you know in
case the first to go out you got to keep
the community safe well get this you
don't feel anymore dude the neighborhood
watch is now an
app on your phone oh I'm still good out
there doing it I'm still gonna do it now
you might be wondering how does it work
the apps called neighbors it's by rings
come be behind those cool video
doorbells that I use the security
cameras oh yeah the neighbors app you
receive real-time crime and safety
alerts from your neighbors it helps you
stay informed and let you know what's
going on in the hood in the neighborhood
that is it's completely free you don't
even need to own a ring device that's
right
open the ring app and go to the
neighbors feed browse through the feat
of alerts reported by your neighbors so
now you guys are on our network it's
teamwork
it could be somebody stealing an item
from somebody else or somebody's kid
being out in the street and nobody knows
about a lost pet how about returning
misdelivered packages a lost item
whatever it is the fact is this app is
making it easier for the neighbors to
work together and keep the community
safe millions of people using already so
if you want to help and make sure your
neighborhoods safe
download free neighbors app today go to
ring.com / k 80s download from your
phone whether Sanai phone Android
whatever it is go the App Store download
the neighbors app that's ring.com / k
80s make your neighborhood safer today
with the neighborhood's app by ring yup
keep tabs on everything I lost the
canary last neighborhood I was in and
nobody had the devices and and you wish
they did oh I miss you flutters trying
to keep lights on you guys aren't ready
for some debate club get it going Exxon
Jersey I'm sweating my girl the squirrel
fight yeah
nibble first nuts oh you know him from
waterskiing on the internet first up we
got Matt madura from Hamilton at New
Jersey this is Matt Jersey baby
he's a Jersey boy yo burnin what's going
on guys there's Matt from Central Jersey
I had a question for you guys which
movies are better Austin Powers movies
or Wayne's World gang gang [ __ ] a buzz
buzz
Cheers
are we doing jenkem you've heard a
jingle mm-hmm Django seen dinkum je nkem
haven't seen me do it in years but it's
a basically but hash they call it it's
um gasps huh you smoking a sin against
oh good for you man
that's that Jersey sure smoking ass
smoke that ass robot now jenkem will you
read it out to us they're dead get the
toiler oh wow it's a disgusting drug
made of [ __ ] where you familia Nabal une
on top of the bottle and wait a few
hours or days and then inhale it you
urinate and put Duty in the arm jug and
put it in the yard and let the Sun get
it and then you smoke a gas builds up in
the throne and then you huff that hit
you I don't know if I've done it or not
bro dude who smoked [ __ ] go get a job
and buy some real drugs steal from
[ __ ] sharper image and buy some drugs
smoke and [ __ ] and piss that's what that
kid did there not smoking it dude it's
called blood hash and they're using it
to get a high okay rich guy rich guy
over here doing fancy drugs over here
with your $90 bag of cocaine meanwhile
young buck out here is just you know
he's in turds
yeah he's toughing him he's not smoking
them lepton brisket turns good for you
bro there's no fire involved you the gas
builds up in there cuz it's noxious and
it builds up in that jug and you take
the top off and hit it bro they call
that that [ __ ] New Jersey who said
Jersey Shore huge oh oh yeah man that's
beautiful dude that's called that that
Tucson gas pipe yeah that's that
catalytic converter right there son oh
and what did this guy want to ask noble
movie better movie franchise Wayne's
World or Austin Powers well there's only
one way knurled mister there's to all
that's right there's two out there's
three Austin Powers Austin Powers Austin
Powers was definitely unique I mean
you're talking dana carvey against mike
myers mm-hmm that's so tough cuz Dana
Carvey he's just a little bit before
like he didn't have as much
success in our generation as Dana Carvey
was I mean Dana Carvey so talented he's
so talented still is he still does live
shows Dana Carvey his live shows and
then [ __ ] Seth Meyers as in Mike
Meyers
he made Shrek and just moved away from
humanity
the murderer dude you took him out no
your that's Mike Meyers
yeah same guy Michael my are you
thinking of Michael Myers bro but Mike
Myers got so rich off Shrek you don't
have to do anything I would say God is
far as being original we'd say something
let's say us to be Austin Powers I would
go Austin Powers as well man because uh
what was the other one Wayne's World
with uh Bohemian Rhapsody that made that
song [ __ ] yeah yeah well they're driving
to the [ __ ] yeah
well here's the thing the other person
in Wayne's World was Mike Myers yeah
yeah I know that's why that he's asking
with which one though you got a pic one
yeah the guy played both movies which
one do you like more oh I thought he's
asking Mike Myers are Dana Carvey
nope this dude's on but hash dude nice
he's smoking that [ __ ] urine bro
he'll smoke it dude that's what he's
smoking right there you failed tomato
twist at Chernobyl dirt twist
oh that's called that : Chernobyl dogs
out there popping [ __ ] lung percocets
bro if you yeah I mean jenkum is an old
age hitter bro and I if you want to send
in a video of somebody doing jenkum and
asking a question bro sending please you
know I'm say also powers
that's 56% Austin Powers as well and
what was the other one again Wayne's
World
wait started on Senate life though yeah
I'm saying yeah but so wasn't that like
they already had oh that's a Gosling
powers he wrote everything off so he
played dr. evil fat bastard cute in my
belly
come on oh he played all that's true sex
robots yay Plato discovered true with
our you have
and that was based off Lauren Michaels
you know that that character is Lauren
Michaels from Senate life that's true
[ __ ] bra what's up next this is Joshua
Turnbull from Kate Town South Africa no
[ __ ] South Africa I got a debate club
for you are you about that smooth peanut
butter life or that crunchy peanut
butter alone gang gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz little young red yeah brother
gang again they call him genghis brother
and a beautiful young fella dare from
over there by Cape Town and ayah that
red that fire Harry Potter out there in
kata dude some kids buried me in a sand
over there in camps by one time outs I
think it's around the bend from where
you're from and they buried me in the
sand over there and kept blowing weed
smoke into me into my body and then in
my holes in my face among orifices and
I'll say this dude had a good time
sounds like a good time his question was
smooth or crunchy peanut butter oh yeah
dude crunchy all day I don't like that
smooth [ __ ] I like a little bump in the
road you don't say I like a little
crunch you might say anyways bro
oh come on to my sandwich throw that
rocky road peanut butter and jelly give
it out dawg no what is this crack it
away
call the police dude yo dude oh who are
you chin Chin's looking for his look
this is Jin looking for his car hello
911
yeah I lost my keys oh I should check my
house okay I'm gonna go look there hope
I found him yeah dude bump in the road
is never better described a human being
in his whole life than you I think
Brendan let's crunchy peanut butter baby
I'll say this crunchy is good man I like
to get I like that I like it if you and
I used to eat so much it would get
caught in those holes in the back of
your mouth behind your teeth yeah and
waterworld Gilda back in your Waterworld
gilfs yeah dude back in those [ __ ]
GILF Anna Dee's baby I'm sucking away
the distance mako shark gills yeah so I
go crunchy to man and I'll tell you
what's truly beautiful dude if you have
a grandmother that cares about you they
make it as peanut butter and jelly
sandwich and else would put butter on it
mmm
and my god dude it'll make you put your
dick inside of yourself man it's yeah
yeah I'm with you man crunchy all day
[ __ ] smooth it's good yes mood peanut
butter bruh that's really just a prison
lubricant I'm going crunchy again gang
56% smooth peanut butter [ __ ]
psychopath did they all go to public
school right there Brendan that shows
you how different people on the world
there's 56% of people can't even handle
a little bit of crunch in their mom
yeah they want things too easy yeah a
little crunch in your mouth it's not
gonna go down so easy it's might be a
little dry yeah I get a full [ __ ] nut
in it
I like the struggle man dude I like
being around airplane where somebody
dies from a peanut allergy okay call me
old-fashioned I'm with you man I get a
little challenge maybe I give him CPR
with a mouthful of crunchy peanut yeah
yeah that's called
yeah I think it's called working in
retrograde brother yeah yeah but I say
this I like to know who on the plane
can't handle the [ __ ] almond you know
what I'm saying
awesome almond the Lord's looking for
him up next this is not killing tanner
Harpole from Fayetteville Arkansas favor
beautiful town fayetteville Fayetteville
- hey Bo and Brennan this is Tanner from
fable Arkansas whoo damn Pig I'm one of
the 30 people in the state who have
internet so I'm using it to ask this
question
it was survived longer in prison between
you two Oh somebody's pocket and
something that mouth warm with smooth
creamy peanut butter they said over
taking my own 600 years to get out of
their prison time but burning shop did
it in less than 16 right yes in the
problem is let's go be let's don't lie
that Derek isn't Morgan
Freeman's son first of all you look like
Morgan Freeman bro who would last longer
in prison I think we gotta go to the
culture corner man because white people
are definitely me I'm imprisoned an
all-time high right now so and like I
can't join the white supremacist yeah by
2/10 okay damn you're too tall dude rule
number one about being a white
supremacist they're not short work low
bro you know I'm saying you want to be
the guy Iggy you know cuz it's all wood
to get hit first here's the other thing
remember before you answer Theo has long
hair smooth skin and no tattoos he looks
like a lady
carry on answer Wow I think the only way
feel survives is ya keep from sucking
dick don't say that kind of stuff at the
end at the end of the night he starts
telling one of his steel stories before
they rape him and ever he's like oh
finish your story and he's like I'll
finish tomorrow I don't think either
what I was to do very well in prison do
you would be a little [ __ ] Christmas
turkey in prison boy yeah dude I kind of
know how to fight gonna be that's I
pictured prison going for you
the first minute well you can't go 40
seconds without talking about another
man blowing another man dude no when I
look at you also look I'm sweating like
I'm going to prison yeah what you're
saying cuz you can't even handle the
question you can't handle the truth boy
yeah I'll mitt I wouldn't do well in
this guy say that first of all you are
bigger than me bro your butt is bigger
than me and your behold your be hole is
bigger than mine your mouth is bigger
than mine
your nose it's very feminine yeah but
you can't my nose nobody's into that
they're not like oh who's that sexy
rabbit with thank you grab your here
come on bro yeah dude you're going down
bro yeah I might get shanked at least
I'm not getting butts in my face yeah
what's in what your dick no dude I got
take it there man people are putting
butts in your day I don't know yeah I've
never been a prison dude
yeah isn't my problem is I don't know
who decide with it's a race war in there
I'm so blacks don't like me I look kind
of Mexican but I'm not mixing I don't
speak Spanish
bro whites don't like me yeah you're
that tall Mexican little [ __ ] fun
bunny that's all you know ones will you
be going fun buddy they're looking at
you going that's a fun rat say with long
hair and a [ __ ] big old bottom lip
that thing's got the bubonic plague yes
what they're saying they're not gonna be
coming at me what do you think cat come
on cat who's who survived in prison I
feel like people would bum-rush Brendan
and that I think feel would get away
with slinging Goods like ramen like I
feel like he'd be resourceful like Terry
Crews in The Longest Yard he's that guy
who could get you McDonald okay so
you're saying that Brendan would
definitely get attacked well you would
be like a meet-up for dicks no no she's
not saying they would rape me she's
saying they would kill me
oh you think yeah they're not run a
train on me
they run the train is gonna be super
friendly to you and then slowly like
that's just a [ __ ] and they see you
know oh wow okay it's just with my mouth
oh you can clean that out with my mouth
for sticky buns okay you want a Twinkie
now to my but that's how we read then it
slowly it's a snowball of gayness in
prison Jesus Christ dude you're just
really different than you used to be
don't ask you about prison bro if you
don't wanna know the truth you can't
handle the truth
oh I already use that just like soon
yeah well you can't handle the truth and
you can't handle crunchy peanut butter
oh so when you survive in prison a
scrunchie doctor I'd say there's bumps
in the road I've converted you to
crunchy bumps in a row that your [ __ ]
autobiography bro here's what I'm saying
is this
you think if Brendan's gonna get killed
in prison cat first of all being awesome
there
sexy before they queue you know you're
not they're not psychopaths prisoners
they're not librarian there's still
people Theo you're an idiot
sorry you're not an idiot but you pretty
much also are one you're an idiot if you
don't think you're your mouth is getting
rape within two minutes of Brendan dude
can we get to the next thing this is to
get this guy is yeah seven percent Theo
yeah no [ __ ] what was the question who
would survive longer in prison gang boy
the rats yeah because you be sucking the
boys L raised a crunchy sucker you're
sick man what else are ya no more dick
talk all right try my best
yeah try your best but keep touching
knock knock who's there
an advertisment dog no go ahead you tell
me you tell me Theo no cuz I know what
it is you're sick you're sick sick of
you telling me workout gear no not be
able to hang so others look at you I
think you know what it's time to demand
more from your workout gear the way you
demand more from yourself
did you looking good bro we got some
pounds you don't look like a vegan
anymore really your bowl is a footwear
apparel accessory brand for people who
train hard and don't believe in excuses
cuz guess what no bull is on a mission
to create products built for people who
train hard day after day that's not
myself
no you really it's for noble noble
doesn't believe in excuses or BS that's
what I won't find any of their footwear
apparel with bull nah man no bull wear
and Tara's welcome no Bull has you
covered
Wow so if so if I feel like I'm a
quitter I might not be you definitely
not dude don't let the simple design
fool you either no bulls gear is built
to perform launched on 15 no bullets
become a key disruptor in the fitness
industry I rocket you see me working out
all the time
I only rock no bull when they came this
true story when they came to someone I
love these guys already have some of
their shoes I love their workout gear
wherever you want they got trainers
runners apparel workout gear it's comfy
it's badass straight up no bull for a
simple durable functional training gear
visit no bull project
Tom /ke 80s training gear for people who
work hard and don't believe in excuses
visit noble project comm / K 80s and get
your gear today yeah I want to be one of
those people man well you can be that's
no bull project coms backslash K 80s and
Obi ull PR oj ec t comm backslash k 80s
I'm gonna do it man
no bull think I'm gonna do it project oh
okay someone got spayed for Till's
haircut don't touch me robot please on
the back of my lizard on the back we'll
start with our Olivia Olivia well
goddamn she's young huh Oh baby's bottle
why is he so upset zoom on that baby's
face got Chuckie for a baby there man
the thing is not happy dude that's
Ralphie May first of all he's a chunk on
the legs cute kid looks upset that's
somebody's aunt and somebody's mom I'm
not mad at her ass so who is this aunt
Olivia this is uh yes aunt Olivia 31
years old from Washington has two kids
and owns a pot farm slinging that hash
she's beautiful uh they're both
beautiful
it appears they're at some sort of
farmers market she looks like she's
looking for maybe some sort of fresh
fruit
she's a pot farmer she's not gonna go to
a market that already is doing something
she would do did you even go to a
podcaster market yeah dude but she's
she's slinging we not watermelon
dumb-dumb so maybe she wants some sweet
nectar of watermelon oh my god where are
you from dude you're like [ __ ]
William Shakespeare bro like somebody
[ __ ] shook you and you didn't grow up
right either where that baby's pissed to
be there yeah let's do this baby is that
her baby this baby is like I don't know
this [ __ ] or is that baby 70 years old
babies it's older baby look Brennan's
right man and Brennan I really love some
of this stuff you're saying today and uh
and Brennan's right this baby looks
befuddled fed up with this lady the baby
also looks a little bit like Donald
to be honest president Donald Trump who
happy belated birthday actually just
celebrated his 74th verse 70 third 74
not 73 is he Wow the poor thing
that but his birthday I think was like a
week ago but this baby looks like him a
little bit I think who else does baby
also looks like definitely maybe a
character like a young character from
Game of Thrones ah Anna Stark maybe yeah
let's go back to the ant then that's
definitely hotter than the kid yeah you
right about that dude I got out an ant
farm when I was young in there none of
the amounts was fine as a girl right
here Olivia yeah I've never had an
auntie like this oh damn farm a lot of
stuff that my cousin's house every night
boy me too you know put up with that
mean ass kid every night so well thank
you for sending your aunt anything else
we need to know about her no that's it
about her all right
by Olivia good luck selling that pot
girl up next we got grandma Evelyn this
is grandma Evelyn oh yeah looks like
feeling 40 years gang identical and I
love the furniture set in the background
too yeah it's just I don't want anything
to match in my apartment ever nothing uh
and can we what else do we know about
this beautiful well this picture was
taken on her 86th birthday and she is 92
now today Wow oh yeah all she wants to
do is smoke a cig and get drunk off one
glass of wine she loves to dance and do
crossword puzzles and she wore high
heels to the hospital after breaking her
hip that's gangster gangster dude well
first of all when you're that age every
book is a crossword puzzle you know what
I'm saying life's a crossword yeah when
you're 92 the road is janga for you you
know like you're just gonna pull the
wrong thing and break your hip that
she's yeah when you're trucking around
that 92 year old risky biscuit you know
what I'm sayin here you might run into
some everydays crunchy peanut butter
she looks very nice she looks like the
kind of lady who kind of she runs the
Mafia commands attention yeah she looks
like she could just clear her throat and
spit into a pot and it would just be a
great recipe of ravioli or something
she's got that kind of just that vibe
that vibes like she gives out change
on Halloween yeah just a wait lady right
could to give you money but also
secretly to weigh your bag down a little
bit just so she can chuckle a little bit
gonna be struggling down the road just
knowing she put some weak kid up to you
know got 87 cents of weight on a weak
kid she looks like she has a lifetime
supply of graham crackers that's what
she yeah she looks like she definitely
you know in Ephrata to get a man off if
she has to about you excited by any
means necessary she looks like she means
business
oh she look like she'll blindfold you
and just kick you in the dick till you
ejaculate she got that some people are
into that man oh let's go to the culture
corner for that cat what do you know
about that pic well just like foreign
types of getting people off kind of you
like people offer Cal a lot of money to
look at their feet oh yeah you know that
no well now you do okay I've got some
weird offers some people are really into
feet I don't get it kind of their offers
did you get some guys actually like to
get kicked in the nuts yeah I've gotten
offers for photos of my feet ah old
socks
I've asked somebody has asked for like
two week old socks before oh yeah shoes
this is not American um pictures of my
dad's feet - oh wow okay yeah a
father-daughter feet porn or just yeah I
think asian feet are in high demand
right now what'd your dad say was he
open to it or he's thinking about it oh
wow yeah he said he'd get back to me and
do you do a lot of cam modeling or
anything like that cat oh no
okay I kind of wish I did though yeah I
can see you doing something we can't do
that here and we don't do that kind of
stuff so you can't do that here cat well
you could yeah where were you Sadie what
do you think this old lady well any
other cat it's B what are we talking
about I don't even know shout out to
this old lady staying alive smoking cigs
what else we got forensic I got hits all
the buttons that are on the table even
if they're not for him call button
button mashing visit yeah that's it for
formal managing that's your prison
nickname but we're gonna jump into the
relationship advice this first one is
from Andrew from birthday man
sorry Theo it's okay I'm sorry - it's
okay but perf from Western Australia
this is Andrew yang buzz buzz buzz dos
lethea I gotta apologize man here's the
story I uh I live in Perth Western
Australia
waa I actually slept with a girl a
little while ago two weeks ago I woke up
in the morning doing some icebreaker
stuff you know trying to make that
connection I showed us some of your
stand-up that LSD bit where you you're
doing the jingle bells stuff opening for
Coco Diaz [ __ ] hilarious man much
appreciated a bright idea that you would
down the road from me watching my local
team play Ozzy rules football so oh my
fault not yours
Brizzy here's the question Brendon both
of you I got a four year old son I have
an ex-girlfriend who ran off for the
best friend of mine I'm trying to be
that good dad but I keep saying the dude
the best friend I keep saying on the
street and I want to put hands on him
what do I do
be a good dad ignore it forgive give me
some advice and gang buzz buzz buzz
thanks for the question yeah thanks for
the question shout out Brisbane Lions I
think this is one's for you Brendan
really yeah you just have a child and
this you know and you fought people more
than I have dude I've fought more
animals than you but you fought more
people than I am yeah if it came to a
kangaroo I throw it your way or women I
thought your way but find American
animals mostly yeah but will you answer
this guy's question please um so here's
a four-year-old listen he can't be
fighting people in the street as a dad
man also it's her loss you sound like an
awesome dude so [ __ ] them let her go
ruin that other dude's life but don't
get in a fight man and listen you're
gonna fight on house in Australia pretty
loosey-goosey out there but in America
you know fight you gonna prison so you
don't lose time with your son don't get
a fight man also [ __ ] them
it shows it shows that it's getting to
you if you fight the dude yeah I would
just you know what you need to do just
go find the most died me dime and
Australia and just start [ __ ] posting
videos of you - slapping kangaroos yeah
I think that some of that's not good
suggestions but I think that um you know
I think that can't be what about the kid
what do you mean what about the kid
here's what I say don't get into a fight
get into a murder that's what I say no
especially in Australia you do that
country is built on murderers no it's
not they have way less murder than us
but they're a gun cuz they're tired
they're all murderers they grew up
murdering each other they're dired don't
you know the history of Australia yeah I
do your mom probably skip that chapter
thanks dude I bet you're the historama
estrellas explain it then if it has Moby
Dick in it your [ __ ] how you're done
so you think he should beat up this dude
I'm saying you should beat this dude up
but not in city limits cat daddy that's
what I'm saying take this boy out and
just take my house shed Oh hide his body
inside of a cactus you feel me yeah
sometimes man sometimes you gotta let
the dog loose but with that said man I
think you know yeah you can also just
kind of let them go on about their
business you know maybe take a little
time outside of town though but you
can't be gonna be stalking the dude or
doing our throwing rocks across the
street or anything like that you know if
you're gonna do something do something
heavy bro go to jail be an inmate don't
be just a guy who just you know goes to
court for a fight yeah you need to get
respect and if you're gonna do it you
and your boys and stomp them out from
the whole population no film it live
I'll get you y'all worldstar you don't
get your boys in there dude I think you
go maybe put some shields or something
on or some body artillery or something
and get out there man but hope they
don't fight him us joking it good luck
my man I would say be patient I would
say rethink about it in a week
everything about fighting right now wait
a week and then think about I'd say
revenge is best served cold so I get
some dimepiece in Australia which
they're everywhere and just flex on them
on the gram
I think if revenge is best served cold
and I'd fill your mouth with ice cube
and beat the [ __ ] out of that guy sorry
I'm still kind of in a bad mood from the
cigarette no you're good man what else
we got we got one more relationship
advice this one though is from a special
guest she pulls out a strap-on dildo oh
no it's not yeah she shoves it him she
shoves it in me she puts KY he puts it
in me and and one thing in his bunk what
does it mean when you're only here when
that happens in your butthole starts to
please Oh what you supposed to do so can
you such a deal you call you know more
about this than friends oh right right
this is one for you dude I never put
anything like that in on my butt you
know when you're doing all them drugs
and steroids and stuff slip some digits
than that anus well you're doing surgery
at the gym bro are you not shoplifting
through the backdoor daddy you feel me
I'm not stealing packages backdoor bro
first of all shut out Pauly Shore sorry
about your father's passing I know he
passed away like a week or so ago and
beautiful man very entertaining and
funny and talented comedian and but
literally to get into your question uh
you've seen the bleeding is that the
question if you do about the bleeding
dude I think you do the same thing you
do it if it's a facial
you know contusion or whatever I think
you put ice on it maybe put some
chapstick on it I don't know I've only
ever had like a busted lip you know I
probably lay low a little bit on the
anal play don't you face off you had
only used toothpaste I know that that if
I you know if I hurt my lip or something
I don't like doing that or icy hot yeah
I don't use anything fancy or don't have
any sweet tarts or anything like that
don't get a massage yeah I don't always
get a massage I think but but I'm gonna
stop the butt stuff overall though yeah
man I think your butt is that should
only here well it's your butt man you
can do what you want with it so I
wouldn't tell somebody how to use their
butt Brendan
but I would say that uh you know if it's
helping your girl out you're giving her
some unique opportunities I think that's
pretty nice of you but yeah just be
careful man be more careful
take it easy maybe relax a little first
go for a run something to kind of calm
down or you know a good idea get down
there a little bit yeah get some so
tight what are those things that they if
you're gonna have a baby they put it in
you epidural maybe so
yeah good luck Pauly D I love to up next
we got a little uh rip my drift we're
gonna start first with Isaac rolling
this is Isaac those ladies were man damn
this looks like they the guy who tattled
on caca Kreger in Miami yeah this looks
like it's identical to him bro he's are
you sure uh Frank Thomas just isn't
wearing shorts I didn't know Big Papi
came back so healthy oh yeah he has two
bombs on his tits this is like Jake
puppy this dude looks soft and petted
look like hush puppy were in prison
disguising name would be hush puppy did
you tell him whatever you want
zing are you sure this isn't Frank
Thomas is hiding in the Dominican
Republic that's what I feel like
are you sure Frank Thomas just skip leg
David since he's retired please put on
some slides his legs away how a hundred
pounds each each Frank Thomas bra yeah
back in the day not anymore
you sure this isn't an apple of two
toothpicks take out the bottom I'm proud
of the Auburn Tigers
Frank the tank Thomas the big hurt baby
hurt and he's hurt I'm down there how
the [ __ ] do that oh yeah shout out to
this guy though man I'm not mad at the
swag listen takes a lot of confidence to
wear a man purse like that no matter
what branded that is was that Fendi
takes a lot of nuts to do that oh it
takes a lot of nuts also to wear women's
Umbro shorts and army green bros with a
designer bag in designer time
man yeah dude switch with them legs
kidding legs out bro good for you man
yeah this guy looks like prank Thomas
like he'll bring you back to his hotel
room and tell you who's prank Thomas and
he's not when he gets you there but he
still but he still hits three four four
in your butt this is this shows gotten
disgusting over the last couple of next
one let's go we got a Dewey you just
dragged us into the gutter every time
bring like me I said what are you
talking about you know that went weird
with Frank Thomas well you what else you
got d we got Shannon from Ohio this is
Shannon oh damn damn damn she ran the
[ __ ] out of that big stallion
[Laughter]
some people are listening just audio
Brendan do you want to yeah it's a small
white girl riding a gigantic horse so
that's why I call it this little girl
riding a stallion yeah and that's a
grown woman zoom in on the horses lower
region female horse yes
castrated it looks like that's a female
horse whose mail that thing would be
touching the ground baby no it wouldn't
dude oh dude you never seen a horse you
ever seen the video mister hands did
I've seen a blind kid at a petting zoo
just petting the horses digging through
the bar and thought it was an anaconda
huh I don't know what he thought was a
furry snake
I think he kept saying baby elephant
they know you keep that things and spit
up at you disgusting dude you took it
there again I'm talking about this
beautiful stallion nesting in [ __ ]
them to collabo grounds you talk about
some young kid petting of elephant trunk
yeah if that's how you looked at it I
saw a family spending time together at a
petting zoo hey could there be any
richer moved and riding [ __ ] horses
white people only am i right no there's
one black guy I think that rides horses
another Subban Subban whatever his name
is
well he's not black clearly from the
Middle East no he might be effort at he
might be I from like actually like from
Africa yeah so what about Freddie I do
how about this thing you know I don't
know what I'm talking about but he was a
black athlete I thought he did I'm sorry
we're trying to roast her what are we
doing with this lady uh yeah we're
ripping her drip
oh yeah so she's clearly Rich's [ __ ]
zoom in more on her zoom in on her
father's bank account there this is a
white girl on a white horse
first of all soup in our 401k she's
bawling dude
yeah look at the butt cheeks on there
I'd put this girl on the barbie
sometimes Derek what I'm thinking about
when you when you see this kind of stuff
and you guys are cultural you and Kat
when you guys see this kind of stuff
what do you uh what do you think about
what do you think do you see a white
girl riding a white horse oh man my
first good let him talk I'm just saying
let him talk go ahead D I don't even get
that's her and that horse of the same
ass ugly there my first thought and only
thought they they both hanging some
cheeks out come on you say oh no white
cheeks babies on white cheek a leak boy
that vanilla cheekers can't what do you
see when you see this kind of thing does
this make you feel like is this remind
you of like a fairy tale like type of
thing does it remind you of white
supremacy no I feel like this is white
people doing white people [ __ ] she looks
like she's having great dinner right let
me ask you this is that the biggest
worse than horrible big is that goddamn
unicorn not that big what
that's the biggest horse I've ever seen
I've seen bigger horses in that I've
seen my friend ed her horse I think it
was like a Levin feet long Clydesdale No
this regular horse man that's the
biggest maybe she's just tiny girl shut
up the white people horses what else we
got
I'll say this at least she has a white
or she's not in danger not like getting
a course of color and like you know I
named it it Todd even though it's a
female horse you know just trying to fit
in with everybody yeah her name and some
people get yeah you don't want to see
that kind of stuff so at least she's
riding a white horse
you know least we know where she stands
she's very clear she's racist I don't
think she is she's putting white horses
you know she's not like saying I'm gonna
ride the back of a different like a well
you're right most horses are brown
aren't they yeah she went you like give
me the white one yeah make this
[ __ ] work and do its own work
yeah Colin powder yeah call him cocaine
boy cocaina
coke Akina lightning but El Cid next
we'll get into a little king it or sting
it just our last segment is our last
thing oh boy yeah yeah you guys went
through this one uh first we got Kyle
from New York
this is Kyle Teddy Ruxpin bond Brendan
ear swabs it's your boy Tom from upstate
New York
I got a king under sting it for you
fellas it's an aviary isn't it we even
getting a sympathy golden drink yes let
me know what you think gang gang
obviously paws buzz buzz brother love it
victim at the end you didn't hear that
there has to be a father
we play that again please in the air was
that him yeah that's them kitty you guys
hear somebody say love you or not yeah
that's some kid trapped in that beehive
made yeah kids stirring up the hive as
we call it you need those as far as
beehive and just in general you're
saying king of sting nests and the king
of beekeeping dude you got a king yet
man although you're basically a slave
driver of the bees you take their hard
work making a sweet nectar and they
don't reap any of the benefits have you
heard of killer bees yeah I know the the
rapper yeah well they're also an animal
killer bees
yeah well they kill people and it's not
good Brendan and so okay well those are
different bees bro I'm talking about
honeybees okay
do you like the honey yes what are you
doing for the bees nothing I plants
outside modern-day slavery they get into
big plants you know bees come bees go I
like you know the world would end if
there's no bees huh hmm you'd know the
world would end if all the bees died yes
oh so somebody read a toilet Almanac
okay look buddy let me tell you
something back here please tell me
something that your mom didn't
regurgitate to you at the house go dude
bees are basically the electrons a
mother nature bro they travel around and
they connect things and they get the job
done they'll [ __ ] anything from a
they'll sting of they'll sting up
raccoon and [ __ ] a flower bro and that's
some ballsy type of behavior too [ __ ]
a lot of flowers they'll do whatever
brother's sucking and [ __ ] brother
basically work for Chris D'Elia and his
deal bro pollinating the world they're
unbelievable bro and they all work for
some crazy [ __ ] up in the attic right
and it gets heated bro and they make the
honey and the lady kills him at night
and so you want to talk about the life
of bees man it's very similar to the
life of rats man it's really unrewarding
but I'll say this man this guy he's out
there with his son doing some beekeeping
I love honey do what I say I'll tell you
this I'd rather die honey read and say
[ __ ] ketchup bruh
that's how I am
I've no idea what you just said King and
honey yeah well whatever Brendan yeah
what else you got up next we got Frank
from Glasgow Scotland shutout Glasgow
and I'll see in a couple of months from
a Thea and Brendan Frank coming to you
from Glasgow I'm from England originally
that's why I don't sound drunk so we got
our tickets for the for the show and I
got King out sticking it or sting it
hang out on sting it um
graffiti lots of graffiti in my city
here don't know how you feel about it
sometimes it's cool sometimes it's ugly
I think but I can't really make my mind
up if I like graffiti or not so uh well
see you in Glasgow bro here's thing
about graffiti if it's done right it's
dope but most of its [ __ ]
yeah else is just kids tagging things
gangs tagging things if it's good work
it's dope how many shitty painters are
in gangs that's what I want to know
they're everywhere
you can't have a gang that has one
decent artist in it there's no gangster
painter out there in Philadelphia every
night like Vincent van gat every now and
then you see somebody you know Arthur
Conan [ __ ] Doyle brah you know don't
strip with a handiwork you know I'm
saying there's no blood out there with
good art skills what's going on here
yeah why I mean you think some of these
gangs would start to hit up the Art
Institute and pop off a couple shells
and see if they could you know coerce a
couple of decent young artistes into
into their cult
you guys are painting all the goddamn
time take a little pride in your work
you know I'm saying
yeah like [ __ ] around this city yeah
a lot of it's the same Philadelphia see
a lot of really good feeding out there
in New York us some good feeding do they
yeah Glasgow might you know but you
can't be everywhere you can't have
unlike your museums and [ __ ] churches
and [ __ ] yeah I don't know where do you
go for good graffiti what do you guys
think about this peach Abbot candy yeah
be nice but it also just a constant
reminder that you're in a poor
neighborhood
yeah it's like it's pretty but I'm poor
them that's why I'm seeing this yeah
you're right there's no graffiti in
Beverly Hills exactly right yeah that's
true but they'll drive across town to
the graffiti neighborhood and buy a
[ __ ] two square feet of it for also a
thousand dollars if you [ __ ] play it
to them right
you're true Umbra yeah [ __ ] shout out
to bang ski here's the other thing what
these graffiti artists are they ninjas
they climbed up the top of these [ __ ]
billboards that are covered in barbed
wire and somehow they get it done yeah
it's like up on the 405 in the giant
ongoing by Southside who says like
something Derek would like a king
nothing on it it's like how the [ __ ]
they get up there
it's like artists ninja warrior man he's
user badass that's a TV show how is that
not a TV show what's up bro
I'd say depending on the area about King
some graffiti if it's good work yep god
bless Scotland man and uh and and yeah I
like graffiti do but it has to start to
change it up I want to see real artists
get out there and do some stuff and I
think he's starting to see that with
Banksy and these other guys I mean banks
he's the most popular one yeah and he's
not a gang member but I hear you
all right boys last one we got cocoa
from a churchville this is cocoa I was
doing a pregnancy test
see yo Greyjoy Brenda broken Gang Gang
buzz buzz to play go through church
village here that's got a kingler sting
it for you guys after traveling for 4
days straight
I'm trying to get rid of this fever from
hell but I know you guys travel a lot
too so I got a king of sting it for you
clapping when the plane lands to where
you're going did your job oh no round of
applause needed I wanted to see what you
guys stood on it laughing when the plane
lands Peters finger bro there is nothing
that
[ __ ] res my gears up more than when
the plane lands if people start clapping
or when I was [ __ ] up or when I'm
eating a meal with my family my stepmom
keeps going mmm
it drives me [ __ ] not does it really
oh my god when people start clapping
when the plane lands - they did their
job 99.9% of planes are landing shut the
[ __ ] up yeah I mean it's like other you
don't see on other modes of
transportation you don't see like on
Greyhound when the bus pulls into the
station all you hear is I'm getting off
you don't see when your number stops
like yeah man we took the [ __ ] right
corner do the new thing in ubers right
now is to try and get your buddy to
massage the driver while you're driving
and you record it I just thought that's
what you do oh yeah but you have this
you have to ask him and then see if
they'll let you do it the whole time wow
that's a new like challenge on the net
yeah it's pretty cool man and I'll say
this dude is if yeah if people clap on
the plane lands first of all if that
happens there's a 44% chance you're on a
Southwest flight to Las Vegas okay so
you're that spirit air this glad they
made it remember Frontier Airlines put
endangered species on the wing of the
plane remember that they always had
foxes on the [ __ ] yeah it's endangered
like a seal you think God looks down and
like oh I thought I got rid of that he's
[ __ ] taste that [ __ ] told you done
yeah mate um what is this guy asking us
up flying in clapping listen it's a big
no there's few things you clap at if you
go to a play sort of get play on the
football field you know I'm saying good
stand up you can clap outside that don't
clamp for a standard [ __ ]
I don't clap when my waiter brings my
sandwich yeah or just do start clapping
for everything you know clap at every
moment you know clap when something to
celebrate life now that would be neat if
everybody did that I go the strip
concert clapping yeah they clap back
with their ass cheeks
naughty man I am NOT is that it pepper
it boys
naughty boys it's an episode that's the
episode of the episode bra cute man I
got to get some rest but I'll say this
also to that guy make sure you get some
fluids do that's what I'm gonna get
hydrate bro hydrate and sleep and rest
yeah that's all you need bro
see wha so I am in Indy and I am in
Cincinnati and Big D's gonna be with me
okay I'm talking about the thing in my
pants Big D is coming about Derek
posting and a son in Cincinnati big
Derek energy dude I like what you're
doing over there and I will be in San
Francisco July 26th through the 28th
there's a problem
cut the carbs there yeah I never been oh
man one of my favorite clubs is it I'd
love to see you at the Cubs I said nice
yeah it's cool yeah I'm pretty excited
so Rob might only be one man what kind
of sick no you don't have a fever we
have no AC in here really yeah I don't
know I feel like the heats inside of me
let's go get rest we'll see you later
[Music]
the king nice day
[Music]